wh
me
ブーム
ん
皆さんの人生で一番の障壁は何でしょうか
受験でしょうか就活でしょうか仕事での大事なプレゼンでしょうか
私たちが生きている中では様々な壁がありますが
それらすべての根本的な要因それは恐怖不安恐れ
そういった感情ではないでしょうか
みなさんも今までの人生で恐怖で足がすくんでしまう
そういったことはないでしょうか
私は今日この場に立ってお話をするのがとっても不安で足がすくんでしまいます
大勢の前でお話をするのは今日が初めてです
緊張して話が飛んでしまったらどうしようとか
最後までお話できなかったらどうしようと不安で不安でいっぱいです
ではなぜ人は恐れるのでしょうか
どういったときに人は恐れるのでしょうか
先ほどお話した受験や就活
それらに共通して言えるのが
自分の未来を決める選択をするとき人は不安になるのではないでしょうか
自分の未来がここで決まる
その未来が大きければ大きい程そしてその選択が重要であれば重要であるほど人は
大きな不安をイラクはずです
では
選択をしなければ人は恐れないのでしょうか
本質はきっと違います
選択をしなければならない状況に恐れているのではなく
洗濯をした先が分からないから
恐れてしまう
先のことを考えても分からないから
人は悩んでいる
そして選択をすることと切っても切れない関係にある者
それが時間です
大体の選択には締め切りがあります
宿題仕事提出物税金の先生に至るまで世の中って
締め切りだけよく言いませんか時間に追われてるって
私なんか
3つのギリギリまで締め切りに追われます
明日の大木だどうしよう
明日テストだ勉強してない
明日てデックスのリハーサルだ
全然練習できてない
もちろん早めにやらなきゃってわかってるんです
それでもなぜかいつも直前になって焦ってしまう
みなさんもそんなことはないでしょうか
しかし
時間は平等で有限です
やはり私たちはこの限られた時間の中で
未来について洗濯をしていかなくてはなりません
だから時間は大切ですと言われるわけですが時間が大切ですというお話はもう耳にタコ
ができるくらい
聞き飽きたと思いますので本日はこのいう間の時間をどのようにとらえてまたどうやっ
て洗濯をしていくのか
そういったお話をしてみたいと思います
皆さんの抱える不安を少しでも軽くしたりまた
求める未来に明るく進んでいただけるようにそんな思いで今日はお話をしたいと思い
ます
少し私の話をさせてください
私がどうして時間に対して真剣に考えるようになったのか
私は以前ハウスメーカーでおうちを作る営業のお仕事をしていました
おうちをつくるのっていうのはとっても大変なんです
お客様によってやご予算やご要望も様々
建てる場所によっては法律や条例も関わってきます
ハッチを叶えればこっちはかなわないこっちを叶えればあっちが叶わないでは全部
盛り込んだら
予算がオーバーしてしまいます
それだけではなく各ご家庭の抱える様々な問題や課題を解決していかなくてはなりませ
ん
ハウスメーカーのお仕事というのは大家を作るだけではなくそのご家庭の人生にも
関わっていくようなお仕事なんです
お家というのは数千万円する
人生に一度といわれる大きなお買い物です
営業所新車だった頃の私はそんなお客様のお買い物を
本当に安心して家を建てることができるのかと不安で不安で仕方なかったです
しかも記述は刻々と迫ってきます
迫るたびに心臓がぎゅーってなるような思いなんです
そんな状態でしたから
完成した相知を見たお客様があれってなってしまうような出来事がありました
お客様が
山中さん
扉の色が綺麗な白色ですね
はいっ
とっても綺麗ですねー
山中さん私茶色で頼んだはずなんですけど
やってしまったーーー
頭の中も真っ白です
もちろんすべて取り替えました
そういった失敗を経験しながらまた仕事での経験を積み重ねるにつれて
どんな無理難題が来ようとも何とかなるかと思えるようになっていったんです
私の中で何が変わったのか
それが時間と選択に対する考え方でした
そんな考えで働いていると色々な人からお仕事の相談を受けるようになります
そのうちに私もいろいろな仕事を話を聞いていると私もいろんな世界を見てみたい
可能性を求めていきたいそんな気持ちになりまして今サラリーマンを辞めて授業を
立ち上げました
今とてもワクワクしています
そんな希望や野望に溢れる反面
授業で失敗したらどうしよう
不安で悩み眠れない日もあります
それでも私が前に進むことができる原動力
それが時間と選択です
ではこの時間と選択とは何なのか
どうすれば悩みや不安に立ち向かうことができるのか
ここで皆さんに2つ質問したいと思いますので一緒に考えてみましょう
では一つ目の質問です
皆さんは
時間について本気で考えたことがありますか
時間には大きく分けると過去現在未来
この3つに分けることができます
ではこの3つの中で確実に存在するものはどれでしょうか
そして確実に存在しないものはどれでしょうか
私はこのように考えております
この瞬間確実に存在しているのは未来です
そして
確実に存在しないのは
現在です
何でやと思われる方もいらっしゃると思います
確かに現在今というのは広義的な意味では存在します
例えばこのてレックスの始まりから終わりまで
しかし私は現在今というのはこの瞬間を確実に切り取らない限り
存在しないと考えております
あるのはただひたすらやってくる未来だけ
それはこの瞬間すぐに過去に変わっていきます
この瞬間を訪れているこの身近な未来は
遠い未来と密接につながっています
それはまるで映画のフィルムの一コマ一コマのように
現在今というのは
当院愛の
端っこなんですね
では2つ目の質問です
こちらも一緒に考えてみましょう
恐怖不安恐れ
そういった感情の実態は何でしょうか
これは冒頭でもお話しをしましたが未来がわからないが故に起こってもいない失敗に
恐怖を感じている状態
それが恐れや不安といった感情の原点です
この2つの質問を整理しますと我々には常に未来がやってくる
そして未来の起こってもいない
失敗に対して恐怖を感じている
きっとやってくる未来が絶対に成功するとわかっているならば恐れることはないでしょ
でもそんな世界は存在しません
逆に私は思うんです
未来がどうなるかすべてわかっているとしたら
それはつまらないですよね
どうなるか分からないからこそ私たちは自分の力で悩みや不安を
紀子様としそう結果として
自分の未来を創っていきます
自分の未来に対して夢や目標といったものを明確に描いている方もいるとは思いますが
中には
目標といった堅苦しい言葉ではなくても漠然と
幸せで楽しい人生を送りたいなそんな風に考えている方も多いのではないでしょうか
私もその一人です
私たちが
未来に対してどんな思いを抱こうとも
今この瞬間も未来は1歩1歩近づいてきます
その中で自分が思い描く未来に対して今できること
それが先ほどお話した時間と選択です
さらに言えば
ただ選択するのではなく
どう考えて選択をするのか
今何をすべきか目の前の未来を床に踏み出すかで
辿り着く未来は異なるはずです
大切なのは怒ってもいない恐怖に目を向けるのではなく
目標を叶えたい夢を叶えたい
幸せで楽しい人生を送りたいそういった願望に目を向けてそこに近づくための
洗濯をすることです
ハウスメーカーず台営業所新車だった頃の私は
怒ってもいない未来の失敗を想像して
自ら恐怖を生み出していました
満足いく祖父が建てられなかったらどうしようと
しかし経験を重ねて時間と選択の考え方を取り入れることによって
何とかなるか
いや何とかするぞという考え方に変わっていったのです
つまり起こってもいない恐怖について考えるのではなく
私はお客様の営業担当者としてどんな無理難題が来ようとも
お客様の満足いく王朝立ててあげたい
安心して進んでいただきたい
そのためには
どう行動するか
何を選択するか
そういった考えが自然と身に付いていったのです
脱サラして3つの分野で事業を立ち上げている今
私が何とか前に進むことができているのがあっ
授業で失敗したらどうしようとそういったをそれについて考えるのではなく
私はこの事業を通してたくさんの人に喜んでいただきたい
この事業で世の中に貢献したいそういった未来に向けて選択を積み重ねているからです
皆さんも大切な視点や就活などそういった場面の時に
いい点数が取れなかったらどうしようとか
この会社に入って活躍ができなかったらどうしよう
そういった不安について考えるのではなく
テストであればいい点数を取るぞとか今勉強するのは将来こんな役に立つかもしれない
就活であれば
この会社に入ってさまざまなことを学びたいまたこんなサービスを生み出して世の中に
貢献したい
そういった未来に目を向けてそのための選択を積み重ねてみてください
因果応報という言葉の通りです
小さな一歩の積み重ねが
未来を作ります
小さな積み重ねは
後に結果となって表れます
その結果は数分後かもしれないし明日かもしれない
1年後かもしれないし10年後かもしれない
それでもあなたの選択行動が未来を見据えたものである限り
その積み重ねは確実につながっていきます
ただ
普段の生活の中では何気ない選択
そういったものが溢れていますよね
いくら未来を見据えていてもどちらにするのがベストなのか迷ってしまったり
そんなに未来に対して重要ではないかなといった選択
そういった時に
どうしたらいいか今日は一つアドバイスをしたいと思います
そんな時は貢献を心がけてみてください
小さな貢献でも相手を喜ばせることが出来ればまわりまわって大きな報酬となって帰っ
てくることがあります
小さな貢献が生んものそれはありがとうという言葉です
その言葉を聞いただけでもとっても嬉しく思いますよねー
そしてそのありがとうが繋いでくれたご縁が
遠い未来で
大きな成果を生むつながりになる
そんな可能性も秘めているんです
最後に
過去は変えられません
しかし
未来は誰にもわかりませんが
自分の手で作ることができます
未来を作るのは
自分自身です
どんなに困難な状況であっても
諦めず自分の選択を考え続ければ
必ず未来は変わります
求める幸せのために
今何を選択し
今
どう行動するか
この現在今は
遠い未来の
蓮子です
今日私が
緊張と不安の中最後までお話をすることができたのも
時間と選択の考え方で皆さんの未来が明るくなればと考えたからです
ぜひこの考えをみなさんの人生に役立てて頂ければ嬉しく思います
ありがとうございます
[拍手]